were so full podcast welcome to the what
so full podcast welcome everybody
as you go towards over here Yemen was so
full how was your show broad and azzam
and Romano's whose killer dude [ __ ]
it wonder white came out that's right
it's all ahead I'll take a lot is those
dead cold loaded did you do a bit yeah
yeah
Oh Asian bro it was okay the same fool
she's married now though that's all
she's married uh who else came up the
student [ __ ] but yeah she was cool man
came out from Inglewood [ __ ] he's a
909 come by Carmen rather look like are
all right
he was that God Toby hates with hair
tell me he looks like he gets cooked
home-cooked meals you know Toby hate
those liberal who though he didn't like
Tom Petty and king of the hill has a
little lip song and I lucky look like
lucky Brooke the boyfriend of a Brittany
Murphy right yeah the girl LuAnn LuAnn
boyfriend yeah yeah the whole looks for
the facial expressions and everything
yeah so was the killer show do she came
out there dude what a blast to did a
thing dude energetic funny as hell don't
good a crawl show up yeah about 40
people here it was tight Wednesdays
right
Wednesday night 8 p.m. a good be Taylor
all the pizzas bomb here to the couple
for the little guy right yeah he ate a
hit a cold bro no I think it the cold
pizza and let go pizza yes it is I like
cold pizza like cold KFC oh man yeah
dude god I don't know what the deal is
what's a pop I think the same any other
but Kate what's up or locally the not
that thing up dude what's up with the
KFC I've noticed that Jerry says that
too like a rant a couple people that
I've never talked to about it they
needed like that cold but it paid good
yes bomb that's the first time I ever
had like that that type of chicken like
that fast food chicken at that with a
gravy in the coleslaw and the bread the
cost was at the Coliseum bro they could
get a KFC with a Coliseum and I went to
with my mom my whole family we had a
whole day at the museums and checking
out the roses
big old group during the town and my mom
the order Berkeley I can believe they'll
even order barbecue flavored dogs others
and we had those we had the regular one
in a barbecue
that's fine my mom and my aunt they went
straight to the cashier started
complaining it didn't give her no
drumsticks yeah we don't wanna dress big
man when you got drunk oh you're a kid
some kids were happy with a drumstick
not me bro Helena no I don't want over
all your trophy and I'll get the press
hold the chicken breast bro no drums
they don't know [ __ ] wing ways
weren't popular back then because we
have the wings you have the drumstick
and what's that quarter piece before the
stars let's die I like to die dog
there's only business because like the
breast has that little stuff underneath
and all that but that's good that's my
thing yeah man you want to depress you
like to ski like we talked about before
but you see love fried chicken skin
yeah dude in tacos oh that's it is a
bomb right Lincoln skin tacos yeah I
just have the prize you peel it off I
used to like I used to try to like do
this how was when I was a kid dude I
would ask everybody if they can give me
the skin we had like me laugh cuz you
can give me the fat off of me and I
would make tacos out of that I still may
I like you know taste good stuff when
you eat it you Neal I got outside sleep
your [ __ ] leave your room huh niblets
none Malindi doesn't even have me tea
bro what's up last night I'm all that
fat stuff I did it that's had very
little sleep till really late
Pilate 2:45 hold on teeny cook nothing
was done now just there looking out in
the wilderness no uh I want to Netflix
chapo series bro yeah what's going on I
do everybody has a series now it's if
they say they said is based on news
articles uh-huh and and they were seen
there bro who was the president when he
took reigns Salinas huh
so cuz in-between Salinas and a fox were
Satya Cedillo
well those are guider who lives with
Willis bald with a brother United States
and
it would work at the time when they
killed Caro Quintero Rafael Caro
Quintero kyouda maka
um he killed the DA AJ the Latino one
and Rica Kiki Camarena from Redlands
California
yes brother killed him and Rafael Caro
Quintero got arrested and they took him
and that fool didn't talk bro oh yeah
didn't snitch
he brought now by the way he didn't
snitch at all but as soon as I'm they
call him of course was an election in
Mexico too and they made Ronald Reagan
look look good good because they caught
him and then they had a meeting
somewhere and I guess Tom the new the
new president came in again and they
started busting I'm they but they
decided busting the big guys bro people
that were like under El Chapo know above
you my bad like come that guy is a
little CLO with the name right I don't
know his name was a big thing big guys
grow on our model something like that
awesome
he was a boss once the guy of the the
Lord of the skies and he had bosses all
over in all over Mexico I had to Tijuana
guys the the Arguello brothers other
Laros other ya know Salix all these
Bulls were bosses before the chapo bro
right right and in Chapel didn't come
into a scene bro like become a boss to
the caught that guy the main guy and
they made him in charge of trafficking
drugs through Tecate okay
the girl he was in charville Tecate
that's right there next to teachers
about his because I'm that fool made a
[ __ ] tono bro he was just smoking
marijuana and he made a tunnel and I got
this with a rumor bro but in the inner
series he killed everybody that was
building that Tonio sad bro he's [ __ ]
our peasants
Mexican peasant see [ __ ] fighters bro
they're all hot bro he goes some food
was in a meeting with Pablo Escobar on
the chapel and all the guys that was in
charge of Mexico didn't want to give a
no meeting so if you introduce me to
Pablo you know is that in a better way
to bring in drugs and faster
our Montecarlo sylvalum marijuana like
doors no man rough oh no fellas he look
and then he go the bus is coming today
go pick among car unions in social care
today he coming on whenever low so that
Foucault picks up the the main guy and
then I'm the main guy was like shock
guidance traffic control like that
so go Chapel goes wow since they want to
introduce me to the Pablo Escobar I
guess there's nothing I will be
introducing myself
so therefore new one of the guys that
was they call it Widow he comes out in
narcos that character covered narco the
Carmen Widow they're full made up he's
friendly chapo and he made a meeting
with Pablo brought it soon example that
food was driving to [ __ ] off flew over
there and was driving to a house like
nothing bro and he got stopped by
sicarios right there they put a gun to
his head and then like the guy came out
he goes yeah so you got five minutes
[ __ ] I put a five minute able to
make a deal or die it was this pitch
meeting his [ __ ] talk about a [ __ ]
piss really bro as I should have been
killed you get killed as the pressures
on us so against power was so big
brother had [ __ ] Mexico doing [ __ ] to
her oh yeah well that's uh that's always
been the whole thing's a pipeline to the
US so that food said well why would I'm
your box brings in the takes brings in
the drugs into it at my California
whatever in seventy six hours so I could
do in 72 72 he could do it in 72 if he
stop [ __ ] around he goes he goes no he
goes I'll do it in 48 hours
damn two days two days but to fly from
Colombia with the cocaine and then bring
it through Mexico so that full flew a
plane from Colombia with some other guy
to place bro with one ton of coke and it
flew into Mexico gassed up or somebody's
filled and everywhere they went bro he
could if you don't bring the little
bring do that 72-hour whatever there was
it was I'm mercurial he did heard I so
broke his own narco free a new right
and it's called-- like coach always or
drug dealers like they knew that it was
gonna come in chop wood ass only threat
to the food and away the trash gamma bro
to keep initiate to keynesian die
regardless so the full thing they could
come up oh yeah and then they're gonna
be stepping up and be about that fool
had cast oh and he got everywhere he got
stopped
he got out everywhere he got stopped
there finally who's a truck I was a DEA
or somebody barefoot said listen man if
you let me go I'll give you like ten
million dollars in cash right now
and another five million for your
friends full 15 million right there they
let that fool go on his Harley flew the
money through the pledge to Ducati and
order a Sonora and Sonora about a border
they had a [ __ ] tunnel and that [ __ ]
tunnel they throw that one ton and two
trucks throw that [ __ ] of Sylmar bro
damn and within 48 hours
yeah no sleep till Brooklyn doubt well
that's one thing about a chop a lot of
people don't understand you know idiots
come up where he [ __ ] he paid dues to
it was innovative like a [ __ ] I
heard he didn't [ __ ] around to if
anybody ever [ __ ] up you put the
bullet in you personally from what I've
read so do it so I have read that out
they killed everybody that that was
involved in that tunnel and chop for me
so absolutely they made the deal Matta
todo que trabajar on and they included
menos Ellen Janero so if they cure
everybody that would involve in the
tunnel shut the engineer cuz you know
he's gonna want more tunnels I can't
kill the engineer
God all those who stood in line bro they
all got paid their money they are eating
four times sandwiches bro drinking sodas
either chips are sweating then those two
foods one foot step back / / Pune let's
go swing up yeah man the talk side of
narco trafficking of those is like a pig
you got a picture JA Friday this okay
I'll pay the bill to nobody man
so getting back to I don't know how
factual this is but
that move the source is to probably be
based on news articles and evidence and
reporters all effed up fool they started
busting the main guys bro after al-qaeda
was gone they would answer the Lord of
the skies almada whatever the name was
the two guys okay pass all like I pick
it up I'll go you paid so we played oh
we paid to the game right in the Indigo
so I know the game is run whatever right
no man you don't understand to new guy
so I don't know it was I played by the
rules we were taking before so you
understand it's a new game and it any
this guy wants to run the whole game and
it was the president are all really yeah
I couldn't with the president told they
arrested that main guy them some
sergeant lieutenant guy is general he
[ __ ] took on a map and he's parked in
the right there they told him that are
you gonna get arrested but you could
they told it they let him give the other
bosses parts of Mexico so right there
they laid out the whole plan of how
they're gonna run Mexico or this guy's
locked up so they're all real honest
took next to Tijuana with other guy
chill town quarries and [ __ ] I'm deaf
we took the little piece right there
so therefore went after El Chapo sorry
like like like I'm it like the Italian
mafia bro John Gotti same thing
he went after all the guys crude they
belong to the main cuz you they locked
up and they really have no bars he said
you guys have no bars out here there's
no boss telling what to do so he said
started when he were in the end and said
I'm the boss and then broke it up that
way they tried taking over all of the
cocktail to his tiny pick in Sinaloa and
I get into more episodes she's gonna try
to take over Tijuana and Juarez
oh yeah didn't but that's cause more
violence too though right oh yeah
because I mean all those dudes know how
that shit's run it's all paid to play
but didn't know that um so when I'm when
they find out that I'm a chopper with in
charge of everything but it's like the
Mexican president
right there and some other guy and they
and they had they have a chance to it no
no no no no no no no Martin because it
goes they want go bigger Adam killed but
he doesn't no no no no don't kill him he
goes little girls to see what else he
does you know cookie the one I guess now
what I think about it um maybe he don't
want to make that make it chop or mortar
or something yeah and all those you know
all those fools are related to right
forever
as soon as a chapel even before you the
bars he'll really like driving around
and the whole everybody in town is
crappy dog oh yeah dude like all those
dudes are like parientes do they're up
third cousins and [ __ ] drop trace back
to buddies at wat oh it's like they it's
like they have other mexico has their
own their own their own masons their own
maze Mason's right the whole little
underworld dog it's a whole culture it's
a tight family man oh yeah there's all
Bloodgood don't think it's just like a
bunch of just that just happened all
that she's been going they started with
weed maybe take people if these yeah Don
and now they're you know they got the
I'm Apollo that's a little hair when
they do that and then they also
manufacture speed and then like now
there's you know boils and all that you
know human trafficking
it used to be people that were just
doing it like another that no one I know
they have what they have people are
jacking gas and gets the lead out of the
pipelines I am it's a little [ __ ] now
there's money to be made
oh man money in it to be honest I think
all these narco or these containers or
whatever they're making more money than
the Italian mob was making back on the
day you know billion dollar enterprise
is dude I mean it's not eating money
dude forget all that stuff technology
all that [ __ ] comes into play dude all
that stuff man you gotta be at the right
gonna be born at the right moment to be
part of that crew huh
that nasai also you can't you have to be
smart because a lot of fools that were
have the same abilities as Chaplin it up
dead what do you write to the top
there's more notorious that and just
crap people I mean come on just the
tunnels alone dog fool that what they
didn't know by the chapel bro I've where
two wives all what I heard like right
before you got married yeah like you
know 21 year old one I come here that a
prisoner party
and I'm added hot ladies house he just
finished kissing her and they like that
kissably like holding her real client
close without love something like hello
sir be careful we kind of pushy didn't
get jealous and then the other wife
comes in with her other other kids he's
kissing home and hug you know nice done
whatever I get along that's how fools
with money do it dog you ain't got no
money you get caught cheating whatever
you get caught cheating you got mad cast
but like and those worlds do it's all
fantasy because he had a lady that was
like think she was 21 she had it had a
kid in the valley about four or five
years ago it was on the newspaper and
everything to she came across the border
had the kids no went back she was
charged for polygamy but yeah man that's
a whole other world in a whole nother
culture dog if people say their this and
that or they're connected but it's like
everybody that says they were in the mop
you back then you work for the Mafia but
you're not in the boss you know what I
watching it I watch this one scene in
that show el chapo it was real it was
true true like the acting was really
good on that scene man because I'm you
know how like most people like you have
a nickname starting bar whatever thought
of whatever you know whatever whatever
they call you but somebody call him El
Chapo and you could tell right away that
he didn't like the way the food sales
chapel that food looks he looked mad bro
like he wasn't in a chopper like a just
a chapel more like the short
[ __ ]
El Chapo let's true rice but it's a way
like some like they'll get mad you see
the big name and long work the wrong way
off I'll be using the wrong tone doubt
it well don't talk to bring our total
carbon but there's actually this for
real right there though that's a lot of
money dog a lot of money from Colombia
there when I was um I remember we were
hanging out with that um that band
leader at the Laguna
Saginaw and the telling us about the dog
[ __ ] I'm drug dealer they run into a
Monterey oh yeah when they got pulled
over and they doubt me I was like
raising no man I don't know if it was
I'm Nino brown from the cumbia kings oh
oh oh these guys he said that I'm here
to do a gay one time
as I picked them up they are picked up
by SUVs and they blindfolded those fools
all the way to the gig and when I got to
the gate a unblinded fall I'm blinded in
it and they did the gig and could
blindfold them again and they took off
who takes who booked these gigs a I
don't think you'll get booked really
take it to the furrows yeah they'll give
you money whatever but you didn't hear
that stories got one full of saying was
on the road and they got pulled over and
you got pulled over those big ears oh
they didn't know those fools they were
they were playing for another band and
they got taken to the interior side of
the road and there was like ten trucks
with the lights all pointed and they had
the tour buses and they made those fools
play acapella with the instruments and
no microwave are you done no yeah but
they kept on like play that same song
over and over and over I was like a
three-hour little mini concert forum and
at the end those dudes all took off left
them there and gave them big old chunk
of cheese damn
just like that instant party you had
told me that uh that uh it was love
still is another situation where the guy
kept he play play dumb that comfortab
androids like see own 60 times yeah well
yeah that's documented in the was the
Rolling Stones did an article on him and
he said have you guys ever played for a
for a narco guy or whatever it is I yeah
this isn't a 80s dog and late 80s oil
chapel yeah there was it yeah but I
don't know who they didn't say who it
was but they took him there and they
made him play that song that's the only
song he wanted here over and over you
know what to play the same song like 60
tyre and they got paid like though it
was John Holmes everything they need me
mean Amy oh [ __ ] $60 ask them out know
what I'm gonna I'm a work loss feeling
alright imma ask him bro backstage yeah
this is like hi bro I'll be dude badass
their own Ella look at that I'm not old
enough to be your dad dawg orale
what some food well Gio tourists having
a baby ladies and gentlemen having rain
Hughes what baby his lady's pregnant the
baby's coming to come out shining my
mother he goes a baby
this imagine was about imagine him as a
father a little yeah man along the way
was a little little extinguisher looking
like Country for Old Men look you'll
name out the full head it's a full
senator but you probably will be aboard
Baldy yes I Jerry from little gloss goes
someone come out of here dog I came out
a full full bushy hair Brandon a way to
climb trees dog I was all jungle boat
dog what's his name uh what's a little
kid's name on jungle book Mowgli Mowgli
how you made it up there Mowgli right
you're like no a word but you know
exactly what word a tipple just [ __ ]
just make it up off yeah I'm good [ __ ]
skip going dog it's whether you know
that guy bro guess it for george
costanza
whatever were some fool man
thank you everybody for the great
responses and the nice thing you get
wrote about is about having you know why
I think you know what I know go ahead I
don't talk like daddy
dude I was an awesome podcast solutely
right when he walked in you know then
then came the Sun all right right on and
then I'll Katrine dog haven't seen him
in a long time where does our greatest
representing but uh it was cool man it
was like taking a dip in a cold pool on
a hot summer day dogs refreshing great
work awesome man favor one so far
yes man okay we're gonna have Marty
Moreno back and I'm man I was thinking
like gum doing a show brought together
night up that I also like you know man
you sit down man and you start thinking
about I'll see about Martine I said we
could have a one night of Marty Moreno
and Phillipe Esparza called a night of
stories versa we're safe Arzo and Mikey
Moreno and Marty Moreno do like maybe
like 30 minutes of no stand-up roaches
like there was that one time because he
lectures like talk and point bro like
like a bedtime stories yeah man but no
stand up bro standard just one into me
night look at me man enjoyed his way to
midnight trying to squeeze myself in
there somehow you need an orchestra
bringing a saxophone into a band the
dude it was awesome dog it was awesome
bro and um I ran into um who I ran into
Palmer Lodge oh really weird you really
that flat fool
I did that show and I did the show at
all with a West Side comedy theater on
Tuesday night okay I seen a little tweet
yeah man so I wanna get out once a night
once a week somewhere you know so I did
the the West Side theater what's that
kind of Oh some guy from black comedian
named Mitchell okay analyst and Mota
Moshe um Cameron Christie okay yeah he
he did pop for you at ice house Ian
Edwards
although the community winner purse oh
man he was funny is it the spot where
what's-her-name's filmed this special
then right yeah yeah yeah
it was cool man I went up there and I
just um I recited my jokes to get used
to them right and it was cool man
and what's the Comedy Store that was
what last Wednesday right how was that
it was good broke the great comic great
comics man all then but um you know you
want the whole show everybody was funny
man but when you know me bro I like the
silly comedy bro
you know it was awesome I gotta say man
Jon REEP always fought kill me bro well
you know he killed Rahl and then that
chick bro up Ellen Ellen or killed the
one that used to be the doubt with the
dice man she's working to come here bro
sir Chiana broker Elinor Kerrigan Sarah
Sarah Tiana I see she opened up killed
it and re went up and it was a I think
it was a British guy what was his name
re is name that's Chris Martin Chris
Martin yeah very nice gentleman back
tation Chris Martin's the same name of
this guy is Coldplay yeah yeah yeah yeah
mate school oh yeah
st bird bro
I leave early at every show that's how
you squeeze into this pot tonight right
that's right
see ya oh what a blast man whatever man
a lot of people showed up for that $5.00
show best deal in town it was a good
deal in town I run into a [ __ ] fool
who does and she was there ah George
Perez was there bro
and now she's George Perez and I see
them over there got overlooked and I
said I did a little without a selfie
remember with my Instagram I see shots
with George Perez we got - Peter Matt I
sandwiches
my right all right hey that I like
getting bagged on that uh-huh hi that to
excuse the wind open the coke-bottle the
podcast right
it's called GPS George Perez story I hit
a mob man to do a podcast man that he
said we're doing here he has to like he
never been asked yeah I asked him to
consider I say he's down
we're go to a podcast word he does we're
all together it's a wonderful podcast
they Jose is your stories so I'm man he
took Martine Marin and so crazy too bro
everyone out if you like to write George
George Perez letters bro when he's
locked I'm surprisingly loaded bro and
Parkhill I start writing bro and I
wouldn't stop bro I'm writing like
wasn't name brother
like [ __ ] now chinaski borrow so
Bukowski bro that's a napkin
that's an alter-ego bro when I would eat
like when he we're now charged Bukowski
right if they knew they were Charles its
janeski
Henry Chinaski bro so sorry Harry
shlonsky is only like the alcohol leg
bro
they're folks fat chicks and rights at
night what I live right and drinks wine
bro like this [ __ ] ah that's a candle
Brolin people I love people things of
great writers there are other great
writers I feel my all the time
when I do these shows at the Comedy
Store and Westside theaters and you
could tell man these guys really love
writing like they're always that under
writing all the time the comedians that
I meet you know they're not like
[ __ ] writer you see a Starbucks just
other typewriter and I've stopped at
their office I could see this guy really
writing collect like Charles Bukowski
bro all [ __ ] up so that's where I was
I was running George Perez I later like
Henry Chinaski and and I'm writing I
wrote I would like a five-page letter
bro I'll load it and then he will call
me and like random night right in the
middle of night was some fool what
you're doing free dog what you doing hey
did you see a big old bull GI looking at
going or you're due today so we were
talking I'm I'm glad I got out and I'm
great hanging at the Comedy Store man
because you get lost and follows the
loop hangs on the east side the whole
time or hanging on a [ __ ] and being
labeled a Riverside comic or being
labeled as a Orange County comic once
you talk people start calling you that
orgy just an Orange County comic she's
just a minor battle comic theater he
just a san francisco comic it's said to
leave that area boy and go in and um and
break out and get out of the norm
because the norm can leave you stuck
somewhere right expand your horizons now
you remember that guys just stood in one
place out I always kept on just going up
[ __ ] anywhere dogs like we're like
idiots those our time in our lives when
you and I were not kicking the record I
was like I was like Parker lower our
time right and you were doing your spots
tour I was just doing the spot going
under smoke little J do spot creep you
know there's some people you know cuz
it's not necessarily political but some
people try to like off I talk to this
fool I can't do this or whatever or
[ __ ] talk [ __ ] and they'll
[ __ ] still ask a fool for a spot I
was always straight if I don't like
y'all just [ __ ] with you you mean but
I'll just go everywhere though just in
my little truck middle car I was on um
al Madrigal Rosana el mágico podcast
that's you guys did that that's a new
one right yeah the audience comedy they
brought it back and I did um the first
episode how's that for the hour man that
but um I'm going to do someone's podcast
that that person needs to be a
professional podcaster like I'm a dork
because man I start going on a loop I
thought getting off subject and he kept
calling me back let's get out and stick
to the script buddy let's turn back and
get back to the time and we were talking
about the time anyway no need a comedy
and he first came along and yeah he
killed somebody bro who measures are
there to kill somebody man
well like he ran him over and so or
something like oh I'm sure it will mow
lawns for a part-time job rightly
shudder Iraq and then one time brother
he'll put 200 more oh man lon and it was
not mad to hire or to go for the man
went out there bruh had a heart attack
and died oh do you not think it is like
choking somebody to death in the USC
movers of dead oh yeah the old guy
decide to look I'm not thinking is like
doing the lawn mower bro you understand
bro I could have been help measures
alright they're burning his glasses he
killed somebody dude IRA crazy ass story
do not already Lang story but I open it
dad on the roof well the day he didn't
help us - faro yeah but also - I guess
you're close with your father man that's
something you take for in forever
well I guess that's the issue that he
has but I guess the in the same ladder
that he used that slipped off the UM
whatever I guess you put it on a bench
he stole it but what the his dad stole
the ladder dog I remember yeah well I've
been listening this podcast and he said
that uh so they try to get a lawyer to
sue he's all said he's like yeah my dad
stole the ladder all right here's your
paper see you guys later
you can't do like that dog or try to use
some angle to get some money out but
yeah he said it was bad for them dude
after that that go on welfare all that
[ __ ] but my cousin dude she's a girl she
was driving at night didn't Mexico dog
and I guess she didn't see this fool dog
and she ran over old man dogs fools like
50 or not read
highway on the highway getting off an
exit or something I don't know how the
story went down coming for us yeah
pedestrian fool like random over dude
and then I guess through somebody to my
uncle new and you the guy in charge that
jurisdictional general dude got her got
her off the hook but yeah man
and she doesn't talk about it you know
I'm not supposed to be talking about it
myself but you know she was escorting
all that hell no got off the hook dude
somehow was just a civil matter
no no uh no uh you know criminal charges
well if you want to run over somebody
man make sure you run over somebody that
doesn't pay property tax and I heard the
thing in Mexico too and this is just
awful thing that I've seen on a Facebook
is when you get ran over by a bus driver
I guess they run you over twice to make
sure you your dad do because that way
you don't have to go to jail or pay some
other a little [ __ ] fine dude so
that's a little touchy subject there I
don't know what the laws are you will
get through though yeah there you go
some [ __ ] like that I don't know what it
is different in Mexico but yes make sure
you run your ass over we sitting there
grabbing your knee get ran over
everybody Nabucco tutorial vivo Marcello
Marcello class your lovin but you know
the I didn't hear a crunch life isn't
worth as much as it is here too and
let's go sad to say life ain't worth
much and some other places that worth it
makes it cool to like hackus that
somewhere broke on the continent Africa
dude I saw the hustle in the Middle East
a hard song but what was that fool I saw
these I don't know they're pakistanian
organics to know we're up Kenny's and
they have to be Afghan American
cameramen follow them okay and well
gasoline is is very expensive like ended
in this part of the country where um I
guess they don't have a deal with
America they don't have a deal with
anybody you know so these guys the good
they they walk with their donkey other
horses and they fill up their gas tanks
in Saudi Arabia or somewhere where gas
is cheaper and then they go under get on
a donkey and they walk it like miles to
get to this other part of
the desert where gasoline is scarce
there is no gas stations and these fools
straight up like they see a car drop
they stood up high by palm tree or
somewhere in a desert and guys they know
that these guys are there and in [ __ ]
saw those cars gas and they make money
bro like that like that like they split
up their gas tanks and then walk all
these miles and the salary gasoline like
hustling like they're selling oranges
and I've dated a shade a day dang like
who who told that hustle those whose it
totally illegal
you know who they're going to they're
not preacher of taxes or cut across bad
that would be and we're taking cheap gas
from Mexico or la wherever it is cheaper
and then taking it to another country
where the money with it all or the price
is more you like you know your gasoline
cartel now what's funny you say that
because somebody just got busted taking
canned from bringing in cans from
Arizona to California dogs there you go
no man and Kramer somebody was saying
that because I remember that little
episode but uh that they were doing that
that's where they got it from and I
guess said we're doing it for a while
but they got busted yeah man they always
give me more money I always hear I will
see like I could do that dog no no no no
I used to like I to get though I took it
back when I was a little kid you know
you could take the big two-liter when it
was glass and give it to a store they
give you 20 cents right see a Redemption
yes
see he'll do it no more hot none but I
think I was looking a bag cycle I will
look in the back like everybody I will
look ok it paid this much in here and
then st. Louis cheap it's only more
money 35 cents it 7/8 but I like that we
should all take you over there everybody
had that idea huh yeah this is so bad
the hustle what's up my brother and I
are we have like four bottles and we're
walking you take it to store 80 cents
and I buy some chips and a soda my
brother's an idiot [ __ ] playing with
a bottle if I were set the story report
he's throwing the bottle open here and
catching it cuz [ __ ] miss crushing
his face bottle breaks damn the bloody
nose
we left pocket 20 cents
$60 what an idiot that's how bad for him
man bad choices
he only had 40 he has 29 were some fool
your dates coming up we have lobbies on
Wednesday but I have the 28th next week
I will be featuring for Edwin San Juan
at levity live in Oxnard California one
night Owen just the one that you guys go
to Rick where mumble I I think for easy
I don't I think he's come in from Vegas
so he's not gonna be able to do it so he
might set me up to do it he's still up
in there so that's how we're working it
so if that if that's the case I have to
go up early in the morning said
something he'll hook up a hotel or
something that'd be sweet
other than that I don't know the details
on it you should call it in I'm gonna do
I was I have no more shows and I'm June
anywhere I just have the the one night
I'm doing it I'm East LA on Sunday but
that's always sold out so there's no
bothering mention it also we had a fat
boy yard so Saturday you're gonna be a
lot close come I got my two bags and
stuff a couple jackets dude I think I
got old too if anybody wants to buy it
I was also - I'll give it to you for 20
bucks I paid like 200 bucks for I don't
care almost how much suit for 20 bucks -
yeah I was sued man that time it so it's
a pretty insta life so I never worried I
never worried which one the one you had
from one comes along
I bought one at the gap one time I
thought it I thought my fat up in a pity
to a dog I have it full of big boy
little jacket that was good it was it
was a nice suit man
it's pinstripe if you went to pinstripe
huh it's dark blue was very teen light
blue thin stripes for some reason I
thought you're gonna get rid of the one
but I was that's nice stuff though but
when you had that one night at sunset
room the one from Last Comic Standing
the whole Asia one that beige what I do
have I took that's uh huh is something
that wasn't yeah how how you know the
sweet coat that's huge now me oh yeah
never gonna sell for $20 and also I'm a
bunch of shirts man and I think a big
featuring my bringing from five bags
other than all like retweeting and
reposting it is that's cool
we're also going to have um discontinued
merchants that like we're gonna have the
Felipa swirl shirt the white one
okay the original original one is there
any Forex no go for it only reason is
cuz somebody um at Addison asked me and
he sent me a message and he's off you
can say man sell it to him or whatever
yeah I thought I message yeah yeah yeah
with the four x1 because we were all out
of three X and we have um we have a long
gig dudes we also have furniture - we
have a coffee table we have a nice
mid-century modern coffee table it's
menagerie man it's so mid-century man
that I bump into one time we're [ __ ]
up my [ __ ] shameful oh it's cut
myself dude we have a child's daybed
let's go up with it with them that
meekly to sleep in it's a nice one bro
it's white and it has a mattress and the
bottom has three drawers good condition
that's going for what 20 bucks that
ain't nothing we have a kid's bike
that's going for what 10 bucks and I
have a fixie bike it's a road bike which
one the beach cruiser a white one I have
a white one I was to arataura worry too
much
I got a nice hair brushing up lat so
I'll buy it off you did have big thicker
of them tires
I just ate another 150 bucks 40 bucks 40
bucks yeah our place is the inner tubes
oh yeah if you say if you were to get
this fixed and put up 2-0 tires it's $40
I have a fixie fixie and it's good but
it just - I don't want to see on it
no all right as my hand breaks
is it the blue one the white one hi but
Adam the bike has our hand brakes but
there's no bike on it it's a picture or
the freewheel free will is if we will
yeah but I don't I go backwards yeah
yeah I'll just be some mostly t-shirt
setting was like two pants maybe three
pairs of pants
where women's clothes we are Lisa's
clothes size 5 6 and 10 there you go
ladies
6 8 and 10 ladies you want to be looking
for some summer dresses or some summer
boots we have brand-new stuff to every
shop lift it also man our gob there man
giving our pest control rules
how did heart-to-heart I taught how to
keep your house right now and season huh
oh yeah
just don't leave anything out man cover
cup make sure you cover anything this
sugary they said the the colonies and
colony send out drones do to look
whatever you're doing on my new place
bro if I see water I dry it up
immediately well that's when you say
that because that's the other thing that
they're looking for water and food and
anything is a super super sweet they're
gonna get up on 1st April what's up with
birds and squirrels they don't get along
well they're they're all everybody
fighting for food dog not the other day
like I saw a squirrel trying to make it
through the wire [ __ ] raw [ __ ] birds
or dr. ma [ __ ] down yeah well see
that's another thing and I'm sure the
more and more you start observing you're
going to see how that little ecosystem
is from do competition that they're
fighting over all the dates on a palm
tree
are you serious that's what they're
going after damn dude and then uh and
then wait till something dies a little
bird or something that ants will attack
at other birds and I get the treatment
and all those grill man yeah well so far
would you go towards urban so you tell
them what the super berry ecosystem and
oh wow man so I'm I'm not just saying my
dates real quick cuz man I've had types
of the real quick that will be real
quick upcoming shows just the two of us
to go tourists this week reminder that
this Sunday June 25th I'll be over at
cities in East LA for one show only it's
always sold out tonight first Tucson
Arizona at the amphitheater with powers
Regas and tiara Marlowe and war man I
can't wait for that show July 13 to the
15 Corpus Christi Texas at Mesquite
sweet comedy club July 22 the 23rd Tampa
Florida at the Tampa improv July 27
through 29 Des Moines Iowa at the funny
bone West
August 3rd to the 6th
snart California at levity live Oxnard
checkout Philippa's WorldCom's last tour
for all show dates the rest of the year
fat boy yourself fat boy yourself fat
boy yard sale coming up June 24th
Saturday from 10:00 a.m. until 2 p.m. it
will be in Glendale at 128 West Cypress
Cypress West Cypress Street 128 West
Cypress Street the address is also
posted on Instagram shout-out to Vanessa
Gonzales briones who never misses an
episode of the podcast and loves the
show so I run into one paw milosh oh
yeah that's right and he was a guy that
we mentioned here on the podcast that
was driving us when Martine said park at
the mall Santa Maria he was there one
with a date let's date to those of girl
and the she listened to the podcast -
she knew the story or chili with Martine
she knew Martine bro and she knew all
the stories bro people love that man I
was I think man the stress on a person
man man I'm numb it's funny man we will
do about our side we kept thinking about
this side you know like my thing getting
busted with them the [ __ ] stupid lady
made you have [ __ ] grown man your
thirties bro everybody's little black
book does that list should be in your
head bro you go to sleep or not saying
you know don't bring it out but I mean
also - though dude well if you trust
somebody why would they be snooping
through your stuff it's not like the
list was sitting there yeah there you go
cause remember I means I'm tests prior
you never had room you never had any
snoopers in your life bro my whole life
mama dude what my all my girlfriends
should be good on top of our [ __ ]
doghouse bro like Snoopy stays dreaming
about what's gonna find next man because
it's like that's not cool
but I mean you know given the
circumstance your house or whatever but
I guess you use his credit and her down
payment or so I guess she had the right
but I mean sure things do still
infiltrating so shouldn't be doing that
for 100 lose a damn beat and they open
up my phone bill bro
while that and that's a crime however
identical you book it for the hell I got
off King it I gotta go I it's you
should've seen me browse I stopped
putting up a front bro like like [ __ ]
like I was getting like ah stupid bro
yeah cool you want an Oscar that day
dawg I coulda bro
I thought I want king of the hill on her
truck you know you just broke a federal
offense right there in front you're
breaking a law [ __ ] that is a federal
crime I supposed to call the feds on
your ass I wouldn't want you to do it
I had to love and then she'd know bro
like women or it when you just say women
anybody in general who has trust issues
don't find something bro so put the
pieces together but they like women
women like putting the pieces together
bro but you could give that phone to
somebody one of your home used to call
make phone calls too right
no but ya know above a house for dogs
you said hey how's it be right I've got
three two houses for me one for what I
should have told her I let my neighbor
use my phone let me see them guys right
this is a public phone but in order
accustomed to the one that this was a
killer one dog go for Eddie um there was
a date there if it just for example say
October 25th 9 p.m. and she saw her
phone number right there and she saw
that we spoke for 17 minutes I stood I
hung up but another phone call and I
spoke to this [ __ ] for three hours I'd
love to talk about that that's the part
that killed her bro so I spoke for that
spoke for this one for three hours we
had a deal in common
we had a street taco bar again play with
a three hour exam pass an exam right
it was in I remember who was talking to
bro I was talking to the squirrel
and nothing ever happy no [ __ ] we're
just friends ng Korra you know I called
but we just talked we never had sex but
it still man it ain't a sex man it's a
time span you know why spend so much
time talking to her you know she was
talking to me you know it's time spent
you know you like - I'm not gonna happen
now but you know eventually if you
[ __ ] stupid [ __ ] calling two hour
later five hours sooner or later your
girlfriend or figure out - all clearly
talking to the girl first ten minutes
seven minutes now that I see you talking
to the girl
three weeks later I only spoke to for
seven minutes so you [ __ ] to a rainy
day time women I'll figure that out bro
so I could tell that um I can see the I
could see from my hair that you already
[ __ ] this [ __ ] what did we talk it
time very [ __ ] her because he right
here you spoke to me for 25 minutes and
you're in spoke to me of course and over
here like we spoke for three minutes
five minutes six minutes then this page
is posted for three minutes three hours
some of you were investing time and
plotting you know in line and saying
you're into parlor rude ah and you're
shy and you don't like dancing this girl
knew everything I was like okay mouse
key dog yeah [ __ ] you hairy and mission
asking her
are you like riding a full black really
because this chick I wrote a squirrel we
were not on one date and that's a day
that that was the day that we're talking
the day after we went out she got me a
book bro I thought it was sweet let's
hit right you know it's not little
people I like bro like if somebody does
something nice to me like that like take
you to a bookstore and it binds me a
book I've been the goose but right now
Brock I thought that was a good a good
moment in my life like a good date want
to go see a movie that sucked and then
went to them we will eat we had coffee
we hold hands
it would just be in the squirrel and and
she gave me the book on the boat that
changed my life by dr. Seuss
I'll go places you will go
like Rocky and Bullwinkle dug other
places you will go
and everyone reading at the bookstore
Gwen this book is my life
this please to read to me it breaks down
your life right here break down your
life bro so I read that book when I was
six and I still think oh look about that
book I'll find one Frankie what pound
dogs pull by well remove spend the night
at our house we all slept on her floor
me you Vinny Oh Kathleen
so you put up that little pipe but see
fool you never talked to women you never
had sex with and I had an honest
conversation it goes on for a while I
was learning how to talk without having
sex bet that's one sample off yeah we
were three relationship haha everybody
see there's a fella for building blocks
I was [ __ ] up oh she figured rod up
she figured out the game bro she said
okay so you're in foster but I didn't
let me I saw a woman Oh finger but I'm
not a woman to figure out by the time
spent talking her to that I gotta go her
too though that wasn't her first time
snooping dog that was in her first case
she left all right
he's smooth yeah it's like dude it's
like Camilla period oh thanks Katie I'm
trying to turn a bachelor fool and
trying to have your side I'm just
looking at it fair and impartial II
though it's like people don't have those
issues have always had those dish I wait
I have always had those issues they're
just waiting to crack a case on someone
again and again and again people still
cracking cases I think she's still
cracking cases who - my phone is chip
happy better ticket oh thank god you
represent man in the pool dog no but I
think I am but a guy will he's doing
stuff like that
this whole there's a way they carry
himself that gets him busted - girl he's
all cocky now oh yeah well thinking I
like your food or more I'm gonna [ __ ]
about hungry [ __ ] sucks
you're driving so annoying you don't
even breathe around me like this when he
was gonna park real close to 7-eleven
but you know how did more attention you
get it you know supposedly you know the
morning line [ __ ] this I could do better
dog all right it's like moving up I did
but people don't forget bro not dog you
weren't your never you could never do
better you get worse
it gets worse after you get busted doing
your [ __ ] but it's also it's not like a
personality trait or whatever but I
think P some people not all people you
know know what they kind of want and
some people like well maybe I can do
better ii do i hear stories of fools to
cheating in their seventy's 5569 food
did i tell you at the house and i was
living at the tag she busted that dude
cheating because she wouldn't do this
guy one of those students
that's Vicente Fernandez tile he's like
70 years old still Dinah's hair dyeing
his mustache request pays hey dude look
you guys are [ __ ] potato a like a
sack of balls with a [ __ ] birthday
and I'll tell you right here in Eagle
Rock off of a fig and um what's out of
the street there's a jack-in-the-box
right there but there's a new smash
burger this or Ralph well she goes in
there right and she goes in there one
day and gets her food and you know takes
off um I notice his car on whatever
takes off comes back around and sees him
talking to a lady that works there I
know another old lady like her and her
mid-50s pushing sixties not as I
probably have to be in the sixties so
she goes in there do you know that man
oh yeah I know that man so I know that
man - and she's oh how do you know that
man well he's my boyfriend
well he's not just your boyfriend he's
not what are you talking about he's my
boyfriend and she gets into it with the
lady at a at a jack-in-the-box so uh
she's all I guess that dude left her
receipt there that he paid for with his
card I said his name and that lady
grabbed it dawg
so she goes back to the house puts a
receipt in this is the lady telling me
sitting down one day catching me tell me
her [ __ ] life story for 30 minutes
ago what the [ __ ] and I'm being nice
I'll listen to it getting the ear
beating about this let's just take off
[ __ ] this but I lived there you know
whatever let me get 50 bucks off the
rent dawg so um she invites him over to
the housing how you doing I made
something for you so what do you mean
you made something that we're going to
Jackson jack-in-the-box he's oh no I got
something better than jack-in-the-box
Apple comes in there and I guess she
serves in the coffee and then there's a
jack-in-the-box of receipt right there
waiting for him and she's all who's this
and the same lady's name that she was
cheating on with the name of the receipt
on the jack-in-the-box and it was his
name that you know he uses a little
credit card
and he's all that's not my girlfriend
anymore she's actually wants to be with
me still on this and I saw alright let's
take you to jack-in-the-box Donna I
don't want to go to Jacqueline box come
on
they start going to McDonald's so that
flows in and 70 still [ __ ] around off
she kicked him out of the house the room
that I was running with his room because
she under they couldn't sleep in the
same room because they were married they
turn your 50s he's in the 70s though
because I guess her son had an issue
with that guy said not marrying his mom
so he can sleep in the same room as her
but he doesn't sneak over to the room
and have sex with her when the kids are
somewhere else
this is weird that was a weird I read
baby boys hey Doc [ __ ] pop her oh oh
oh dude knows a funny story about pops
because do women love mondo I'm not says
mondo is not like that whatever you can
say like one time I heard big boys off
little dude women love mondo right so
when data as we were with them at the
Ice House he mando's nice to everybody
dog says oh yeah and the girls are
skating I'll keep so mr. Co Co and like
before she even said next fortunes all
he's married to my mom it's like all
right pops everybody knows you know
surety well guy what's gonna slice it
easy ha ha ha but you know that's a kid
being possessive and but which is cool
either way a dog in me it's not like
mondo is gonna go come on do the grandpa
and all that stuff doesn't matter what
yeah what about old Cheney they're
getting caught cheating yeah so what's
[ __ ] moonstruck the end of the movies
art movies little Raiders badass yeah
that Daniel yellows better a dude Nic
Cage is bad to the skin a finger the
hand dudes are all good dude that was a
GLAAD app good is it food hey but how
she got caught dude and then shared
catches her first subpoena but she but
how the mom told her I don't talk to her
anymore
this is gonna stop and engine stops but
it's like boutique yeah but what are you
gonna do though people are jewelry those
who oh my tweener like a princess
harmful the three-pointer the bombs will
they're cooking a little sanguine
bread sourdough mrs. BAE with egg in
there ran the whole household odd ha ha
this wear suits oh my god you stop when
I coat on her a little you know screw
cheating ha like get just doctor go
somewhere like it's not [ __ ] going
and put it on Musk
putting on Musk living and but the whole
see was created her because I'm his
friend was there talking about how when
he fell in love with her there was a
Luna that was a born that was a loon not
every fall in love everybody was
moonstruck dog everybody was refund I
love the uncle and aunt we're redoing
their little thing there everybody but
see I think the tragedy is when you
actually get kicked out of the house and
you're never let back into the life and
there's a new dude in there and that was
outside the window like I wanted to kill
everybody hey but you [ __ ] it up a
good movie I want to watch a good movie
from the 80s right a town strut ass
movie I seen it was a little kid of that
I seen it just recently cuz I was
telling you I was seen it I don't know
what made me see it and then like how to
add that sourdough bread with the egg in
there oh my gosh I have a made it oh
yeah man it was like go home it was like
presto italian french toast yeah dude
yeah man it was a star on its I've seen
the movie man where um
Olympia Dukakis the actress she's make
it a breakfast for armchair just have a
coffee and she gets like some she cuts
up some Italian bread and no and she
makes a little hole in the middle of it
and then she's frying it on the pan and
she throws some she puts a egg in the
middle eggs in it and then she told him
some Marineris
some cheese and a marinara sauce I think
she handles the red cut up those red
peppers on yeah bomb dude you know the
whole thing - didn't danny aiello cuz
you supposed to marry her
he flies over to italy his mom's
approval bro yeah and this is the mom
dying or something and then he has a
change of heart and the brother that he
hasn't seen in a long time and he got he
was already at Racal and there was
little poems and soliloquies or whatever
little what did he call a monologues
dude that's what everybody blames his
brother Mehbooba they've had their spoke
to me like for years and that's yeah and
those are one of the movies you can't
get to you're older and you like go
through
for whatever but it was Bom Bom bad
movie huh real good good
you mean that you give it up the share
dog about our bad how about [ __ ] is
another good movie Madeline 29th Street
dog I a desire yellow was you know it's
weird because to me it seemed like it
was all in that little era of dog little
East Coast life and everything did it
was cool tunes when a share went in and
got your hair redone I go so they'll
probably like gum the whole the whole
arm the whole thing she did when she cuz
she look like are like oh okay later I
know she's all looking but they never oh
really come on she was my mom right
there but that's what's that sometimes
kind of like a coming in an age story
later Katherine Helmond that and also
the other one that can contrast with is
um My Big Fat Greek Wedding what she's
like older like their 30s and looks ugly
and then she like gun with confidence in
herself got her stuff redone and she's a
new woman dog here I mean you know start
dancing and walk moodiness April clothes
they fish throughout color like red like
like lamb what she want to go do her
whole thing it was nice huh she was
really whipped in one place gay dudes
pics of her hair dyes it and she picks
about crazy dress shoes then she catches
her dad cheating yeah it did to me that
was crazy though okay we're like a home
movie hearing hey spoiler but who cares
I mean did go see what are you i refresh
ha to that that I I knew something was
going on with that man dog I didn't know
bro he was actually different I really
love them had after mom and saying stone
telling you bro man went on here it's
that car at the extra cocky thing that
gets you busted but you know what if I
get up treat everybody the same and I'm
not knocking cheating nothing I mean
whatever but it's like I thought the
wife look better than the ladies a
little bit later ladies on hold on
I should not short around them all your
wife looks better what are you doing
instead like she was like show a
redheaded lady a Gucci lady she reminds
me of George Costanza mom darling like
you know built like a little bun or
something like a little Concha
[Laughter]
attention bro right bro
it would be attention booth it was that
[ __ ] book beautiful and I felt like
all into another like beginning what's
the movie ever talk to a girl before you
had sex - four days dog attend school
until two hours two hours yeah like it
kept going I'm sure I'm sure she
probably put down the phone went to go
do something came back and just like
certain humans kept going like nothing
no pmm I was I think I put - Lisa put
four hours one time three well well you
know it's different because I met Lisa
on their social media bro I can just
send her text or an email but before all
that I think I suppose somebody five
hours yeah I can talk to somebody from
ulta especially someone you like you
kind of want to you know you like you're
like what hot role but it's also to like
somebody that you have it just goes back
and forth in the time flies I mean
you're not you know sometimes like
you're on the phone what's gonna that's
plenty of men like a woman remember that
[ __ ] what about whether I spoke to that
woman for three or four or five that's
it took a left on that you have sex man
oh yeah yeah oh yeah I don't know women
know Lizzy staying man but I see how I
noted them all late I noticed them now
you know that you're eg spark I'm gonna
[ __ ] it's just beautiful three
hours now you're like I know that you
like you just fit to be enough over
three hours I'm here now bears wanna
talk to the mental chart dog you get mad
I get angry huh well you can't do it I
mean you know that's what you learn with
the one from the past it's and I act
like a fool now so you be your lady for
one year year and a half I've known her
fly too
you know just it was real slow you know
and you know start talking or whatever
dating people probably saying man it's a
good to Mexico too soon bro
so waited on but 39 I know what are you
gonna write gonna [ __ ] come up with
like what's next the Hawaii
marry her dog
over engaged you're engaged been engaged
for did it did it did it did it it was
you go tourists just a lot of engaged
people today today tip it so you are
having a baby
no you trying to make a ride huh she
can't be a single mom again a-and now
did you see bears before
yeah she's made me so - bro take a time
around
hello she may be four I don't really
know dude but it was well get a lot of
the baby daddy no there's no there's no
contact like that he'll asleep no
there's just like there's no contact
I'll tell the dog once you find out that
you're getting married he's gonna show
up because guys like showing up at those
times believe me they leave me that's
when I like to show up when teen are
going good for the other person latina
going for the good person the other guy
shows up bro just to throw a little
spike at the relationship he's gonna
show up and cement with my rights for
real dog you to show up or try to show
up or somebody in a family's gonna tell
here man yes or with the way life works
hey well you can't get no passes to this
concert player he's like ah blue but
yeah this is there's no contact with
that cuz AMA says it's because he don't
want to see her what I wanna see him I
have no I have no idea on that I don't
ask you know they just do with it well
bro you gotta get married brother
question you start asking buck you don't
want to be surprised
so that should have hurt later man looks
like a madman [ __ ]
good know that yeah miscarriage you
didn't tell me about [ __ ] yeah man - I
know man like okay good guys man don't
know guys don't know how to really fight
but sometimes man when they put their
mind to it and then talk to you like a
woman you could do something hella
devilish [ __ ] to talk like I remember my
daughter getting baptized and I just
came out of rehab and I found out where
it was she I wasn't a back other Church
[ __ ] up that baptism bro making a
scene I'm the real father back here I'm
the one on the arm I thought that way
that George Clooney said but I wish I
had the word right now
I'm uh I'm bonafide yeah man
congratulations bro Thank You doc I
don't mean to scare you away oh no I'm
still I'm sure if we're thinking about
it I'll kill that [ __ ]
oh dude you can do whatever you want are
you nice and tablet wherever you want to
tap-dance but just go tap-dance on your
porch what does that mean that means
whatever you wanted to me what does it
mean where we're going what the [ __ ] you
talking about [ __ ] capped Axl what
would I mean that's headbands
oh no basically all I'm saying is this
would be like Billy batts you're gonna
mess up this party trying to [ __ ] up my
party I'm saying yeah man people will do
that [ __ ] man
like I always tell like like I would
when people who are comics and they know
like like George he got he was telling
me that I'm somebody came all all crazy
out here man say bro let it go dawg let
it go don't fight nobody to old you got
two strikes one and a half somebody will
take you to jail for some reason man you
don't need the hassle I will just walk
away man now they'll just walk away man
it's not worth it plus I was shown
tomorrow yeah that's what up it can be
[ __ ] around these days had dog cat
already the council rather like I took a
laugh on that story you said when you
[ __ ] stop the car the guy had a gun
oh yeah okay I was ready to you know do
somebody's like a sandwich it towered
somebody pulls out a gun what are you
gonna do what are you gonna do for my
hands up yeah good stuck twice in the
chest
you don't want no [ __ ] close shave
like that bro this is speaking of close
shave
our friends at Dollar Shave Club get
your face move and ready for summer by
joining Dollar Shave Club
it's the smarter choice get high quality
blades and amazing dr. Carver's shea
butter delivered right to your door for
an incredible smooth shape it makes your
life easier so you don't have to go to
the store and get lost looking for
razors that are cheap and flimsy or too
high-tech to understand hopefully you
got your father's something nice for
Father's Day maybe
got him a subscription to Dollar Shave
Club maybe you didn't know but what he
really wanted so now it's get about
Dollar Shave Club you did Dollar Shave
Club something here our parents or our
dad will get into hell now ha ha ha just
came back uh even before my friend Rick
that's funny you say that dog because uh
your mom paid all the bills in the house
yeah my dad's money your mom's good at
that [ __ ] you said not good my dad and
it's not that he's good he just doesn't
have time for that she's always
administered the money now she takes
care of everything the only thing
there's these signs they get together
whenever they you know my mom always
been good with that she does all that
said she buddy I'll teach you that oh
you took learned I learned it to her me
too man my dad you know tells me certain
things but I mean all the budgeting
everything that she does is you know
it's at her hands she's always been good
so I'm so proud my mom never told me
that you took all that [ __ ] map your
[ __ ] couldn't get on the phone right
now man and tolerate Oh check to come
over here and pick the team for sure
but it's like my dad's gonna be like
putting his debit card so every month
it'll take money out of it just cuz
you're gonna get razors or anything any
of those services they're still old
school [ __ ] they called that [ __ ] ha ha
little bit to that man to have someone
deliver razors to the house they must
think I'm an absurd idea how she does
the store every Wednesday I'll pick
something up every other Wednesday would
have been an opposite they don't have it
at Costco we don't need it yeah it's
like what are you really gonna just
deliver a razor for me I'm changing dogs
I'm on my pocket I'm thinking of Jimena
Costco member now bro getting old grown
Kirkland does something very getting old
man
Costco is one of these your biggest
field you want to make right now well I
didn't get everything in bulk dude you
know he says so you want to buy some
extra extras s so bro if I like a do one
for 20 bucks that's up on sale as well
as a one of our listeners for a limited
time only new members get their first
month of the executive razor with a tube
of their dr. Carver shea butter for only
five dollars with free shipping after
that month the raisins are just a few
bucks a month
that's a $15 value for only five bucks
your first box will arrive and you'll
get an awesome heavy handle razor or
focus that are poor cartridges and a
tube of the shave butter no hidden fees
no commitments cancel anytime you want
to get this deal join today at
dollarshaveclub.com slash food that's
dollarshaveclub.com /foo is to use it oh
I ran out of cartridges how about the
butter user that [ __ ] to jerk off now
you don't jerk off the more your lady
now bro please even hold your crush that
you did before so you know it's being
used for you to hang around man he'd be
talking to girls scratching his balls
without even noticing
he's [ __ ] scratching his balls
without me noticing somebody else was
noticing I know man
I remember my suffice my ex's yes friend
ray the [ __ ] pervert man this is the
pervert you were initiative balls let me
look at him again she said once your
boss are you looking [ __ ] that's what
I'm saying
like [ __ ] dude check it out I know when
we get scared up I wasn't the only
crotches she was looking at you know she
said yeah man wildlife we were those
tight pants bro the tightest has ever
worn your wiggle endo your way genes I
had bigger pay there's Jesus tired of
passenger window you a data they had
tight pants tired passes I dunno I just
may be the fiber one the way that they
were cut rings maybe were exaggerated
yes I want that light all those are
argument about people who say how about
your generation bring them tight-ass
jeans and flowed ashes they were tighter
dude but then they went bigger and now
they're tighter again dude but they were
different they weren't they weren't uh
he's ending I'm not but I think just you
know big puffy ass jackets make your if
you had a starter jacket and make your
pants look smaller Jeremy but dude
tighter ass jeans down dude yeah on
dudes
which I think do should have tighter
pants and women but whatever though was
so cool I know man speaking of yeah some
people man our tight jeans only when
they were like when I would like I
didn't want to like bust out of 38
but yeah man with your lady shouldn't be
having tighter jeans than you or you
should have title Jesus and I know man
or something other than yoga pants were
some fool shout out to raise Dollar
Shave Club chapter two of us we can make
it if we try
you heard some fool unsubscribe dog for
what talking [ __ ] about us no matter how
what do you say this was a fool he goes
I'm done man
I'm tired of the yeah man's who hate on
you bro
peace lookit I only want brings of the
hosts
I don't channel do you you say yeah man
more than me I don't bad but let me tell
you something dear like I used to listen
to podcast a lot but one thing is I like
is a you know message is blood on the
last card podcast you know homeboy
mention like a handful of popular
podcast we saw dude this one's the
realest one dawg
we're on is here bed a little like this
we mentioned up here man
some people tell delete that [ __ ] yeah
but the whole thing is like it's it's
it's free Dawg you know providing free
energy a bad review man a bad review is
to a review they took time for us oh
yeah I see it
it feels time to our paragraph one dudes
mad I mean you know thousands of people
are happy to can't say anything about
that to one guy and the ultimate role is
a little stand-up comedy cozy well I'm
there I know there's a lot of stand-up
comic the little bit of the podcast
shout out to you guys
keep listening thankee to give felicity
my hope you got learning something here
we're trying to teach everybody
something i don't know why also mad
don't forget i'm on that arm all things
comedy podcast episode with them al
Madrigal I don't know when it comes out
but check that out and what you up yeah
man cup podcast this week we have a I
have a solo one but do that I have
- something happen to my soundcloud
account so I have to do something with
it
my solo one that was gonna come out on
Saturday won't be probably up til
tomorrow or the next day
what's that like we do a solo once I
just do it like I like it honestly I was
like because I don't want to like I mean
everybody has a different format or
whatever but I kind of like the solo
ones and then maybe once in a while do a
guess but I got to figure something out
what I'm gonna be putting them out
during the week but I like the solo ones
I just had to put my headphones on and
go dude I mean what do you talk about on
the solo ones just and not anything I
have two or three things right now about
but there was one would you just talk
about the food in Mexico yeah and that's
what uh what the solo ones about this
this that I'm gonna be put now and
that's just talking about like but I
would cover stuff I have you know three
or four things that I cover and then
just go you know 45 minutes to stuff
like that you have that guy on your
podcast that was on the show which would
show with uh with um I'd wonder white oh
cool II know I haven't had coulis onion
all right were so full podcast check out
what Google Torres he's every Wednesday
in Riverside at Romano's the show start
at 8 o'clock beer specials a good vibe
at Amen if you're bringing some good
[ __ ] but you go back to go backstage
yeah man
man Vinny was there bro he showed up
from workers are happy yeah all those
who showed up are happy yeah there's
even though these deep even that Jerry
showed up with the new outfit though
hasn't worn out in like 20 years
hell yeah but for sure to go to drum
things I'm ready but if I make me you
got a snare war so foot Parker thank you
very much everybody who listens thank
you for the comments the reviews keep
them coming and we're still here we're
gonna keep doing this we love doing it I
love doing it I love a lot of like
getting up sometimes and coming over
here guys but it's so fun you know you
know some episodes are cool some are
funny so much is like a but we know we
don't even know shanaar those we should
our episode we just talked about the
best of the best I picked up though the
podcast we love and we show clips of it
the best story which one's your favorite
man I was Joey Diaz and Corey Holcomb
but now it's the martín one last thing
was with my top one now but he will give
it away he was good to us but the guy
mentioned that our good common are the
best parking on the Warsaw for with
Philippe Road dog day yeah that was a
good one man but yeah we're gonna have
our team back cuz I'm we didn't we just
touched the surface yeah it was more
like a long intro yeah dude it was like
dude it's barely like you don't have to
try do you mean and he was barely
getting into an L Katrine didn't say
anything really too much [ __ ] I mean we
did we get to him exactly dog so oh cool
and there's so much more stuff with
Martine but I mean it's just time don't
get immediate Lube I did it was like
glue by because about three hours yeah a
little been he that easy didn't know
what I saw Parker don't talk about that
because getting pumped up we talk for
skinny ass later
he goes like a Beretta a fool but it was
badass to the podcast but how about the
stuff that we're talking about after
over here in the lobby doorman you can t
go you go charge $50 for that man the
reek though oh my god that's was
teaching Yoga energy the energy
very funny a story though we have time
roll ha ha ha we're so food thank you
very much take you to a zero Torres MN
Lisa as far as our Erin you're an
airborne right here the man behind the
microphone the engineer the hard-working
engineer therefore he may have to go to
the optics comedy show to our tire wife
right there with the neck pillow hell
yeah man but it was a show right well so
for I'm going to be again at the Comedy
Store at another future date pal in July
check it out it'll be with some guy
named cut so that Skylar stone rock show
comedy rocks alright peace out Yemen